Chancellor thank you for talking to us
um can you tell us something about the
status of the economy at the moment I
mean we've just had these latest figures
how are things looking for the for the
coming months well I think it's a very
challenging International picture
um about a third of the world's
economies are predicted to be in
recession either this year or next we're
no different in this country and
truthfully it is likely to get worse
before it gets better which makes it
even more difficult when we have uh big
public sector strikes going on at the
moment but we have a plan in place and
the independent office for Budget
responsibility say that plan will more
than halve inflation over the next year
so if we stay the course we can deal
with this challenging situation and get
through to strong economic growth and I
think that's what everyone wants the
strikes you say will make it worse they
will they well the strikes are a symptom
of the fact that people are very worried
that their pay packets are not going as
far as they would have this time last
year and that is caused by inflation and
so my number one responsibility is
chancellor the number one job of the
government
is to make sure that we tackle inflation
and that will deal I think with the
underlying anger that many people feel
they do feel anger at the moment they
feel a lot of anger towards the
government and you know partly that's
exacerbated by the fact that you know
we've seen reports about for instance
the government not negotiating with
nurses about their their pay is that
right that you're not actually
negotiating on pay at the moment well we
have to be very careful we recognize the
position the unions hold is completely
sincere because of the challenge of 11
inflation on the other hand we also have
a sincerely held position which is that
we don't want to do anything that would
lock in that high inflation rate for a
long time to come so the right answer in
a situation like this is to follow an
independent process where someone
independent looks at the Union's
position looks at the government's
position and comes to a fair compromise
and that's what we think should happen
and that's why we are supporting the
independent pay review body processes
what more or less would you say the rate
of wage inflation is for for the private
sector and the public sector at the
moment
well um
for this year with the independent pay
review body we agreed with a pay rise
for nurses which is comparable to the
private sector and just specifically at
the moment what you know what kind of
Gap is there would you say at the moment
between private sector and public sector
well I've just said for this year if you
look at the private sector pay Rises uh
four to five percent and we agree to a
five and a half percent rise for nurses
next year the independent payer view
body will look at those factors and they
will come to a balanced judgment and we
are happy to follow that independent
process we think that there is a genuine
difficulty in coming to the right
balance between our concern not to lock
in high inflation and people's worries
about how far their pay is going and we
think an independent process is the
right solution but the answer to answer
is that the private sector pays only
about seven percent public sector pay is
running at about two percent or less
than two percent if you look at some
measures there is an enormous Gap that's
opening up now so can you not see why a
lot of people particularly in the public
sector are so frustrated well I don't
say for a moment that these aren't very
sincerely held positions and surely the
right answer this is not fair for them
to get closer to to the private sector
rate of inflation they're falling back
and these are everyone is getting poorer
right now but they are getting poorer
faster than the private sector well the
right answer in that situation then is
to follow an independent process that
comes to a fair balance between the
worries people have about high inflation
affecting their pay packet and the
government's concern not to lock in high
inflation even if that independent
process is out of date which you know
that happened months ago things have
changed since then inflation's got
higher well so will you not go back and
look at the numbers and say maybe that
needs to be reflected well we have
accepted in the case of the nurses the
independent peer review bodies
recommendations for this year which was
back in the summer
as far as next year is concerned we
support having this independent process
and whatever they decide is backdated to
the start of the year so I think it's a
fair process a lot of people have
remarked on how strange it is that even
as a lot of people are facing this you
know winter of discontent to squeeze on
their earnings at the same time you're
cutting the relative rate of Taxation
for for banks uh you're kind of pulling
down various restrictions and
regulations you announced them just last
Friday does that not look a little bit
awkward to say the least not at all
because what we want to do is to have
the fastest growing most prosperous
economy in Europe financial services are
responsible for about 10 of our economic
output a much higher proportion of the
taxes that pay for the NHS and public
services and if we want to fund those
Public Services we need to encourage our
high growth sectors whether it's
technology whether it's green Industries
whether it's life sciences and that's
what we'll be outlining over the months
ahead how worried final question how
worried you about the state of the labor
markets at the moment you know the UK
does look like it's in a kind of
stickier position than many other
countries around the G7 does that
concern you well we have a tight labor
market here but we're not the only
country to do that and certainly that's
something we'll be looking at in the
months ahead okay Chancellor thank you
very much indeed thank you
I think the treasury looks like it could
do with a couple of hundred watt bulbs
as you can see I'm joined Now by our
economics editor Ed Conway at our
business presenter Ian King I mean Ed to
you first let's just let's just talk
about the strikes and and public sector
pay I mean when you hear people like
Jeremy Hunt like Steve Barkley saying
that what the unions are asking for is
it is unaffordable there's just not
enough money to do what they want that's
nonsense isn't it it would be expensive
but it's nonsense to say that they don't
have the money to do that no I mean they
they could Finance you know quite a lot
more spending if they wanted to the
question is kind of what the quid pro
quo for that is and it's worth also
saying that you know even if you're
spending more money on on those wages
some of that would potentially come back
through higher tax take and some of it
would come back through higher spending
but the bigger picture I mean there's
two things there's first of all the
question of you know are they nervous
about the state of the public finances
now in the wake of what happened in the
midi budget certainly they are and that
kind of Inc declines to what the
treasury generally kind of feels it's
generally very conservative about this
stuff but secondly and more importantly
and you kind of got a sense of that from
from the interview there they are really
worried about inflation and they're
worried about kind of adding to that to
that pressure and the fear that that
haunts them in those slightly kind of
spooky looking uh rooms in the treasury
the fear that haunts them is of what
happened in the 1970s when you had this
interaction between wages and prices so
inflation went really high then people
kind of got the higher wages and that in
turn fueled the next round of inflation
and it became kind of inescapable you
just couldn't kind of put it back in the
box so that's what they say but the
reality is as you would have seen there
is that there is a big gap between the
private sector right now where wages are
running away really quite fast and the
public sector where they're not and as a
result you know you can make a good case
I mean it's difficult to compare those
two things it's difficult to compare
public sector earnings and private
sector earnings given there's all these
things like final salary pensions that
make you know it's more attractive in
many parts of the public sector but
definitely the private sector has been
catching up if you want to put it like
that like that way maybe overtaking and
here we are in this really tough period
both for public services for the rest of
the economy those numbers this morning
not looking very good
and so it is quite hard you know no one
is going to be happy out of these
negotiations but as you say it's not
quite as straightforward as saying we
can't afford it it's it's more complex
than that which is why I think the
government's struggling
um Ian just a word then from you on
those those GDP figures we are seeing
growth but but still think we're heading
into recession
well that seems to be the likelihood
yeah I mean the October number was uh
unexpectedly strong actually uh 0.5
growth better than the market was
looking for that I think largely
reflects the fact that there was a
bounce back for September there was an
extra bank holiday for the late Queen's
funeral and accordingly GDP came off
very sharply in September if you look at
the three months to October as a whole
UK economy contracted by some point
three percent uh that was uh that was
from the previous three months uh to the
end of July that's actually the worst
three monthly period since the first
quarter of January last year when of
course the UK was still in a covid
lockdown so that the broader picture is
not terribly encouraging and actually
even where there were pockets of growth
in October consumer-facing Services did
extremely well which I think actually
highlights the fact that there is a
still this big cushion of household
savings which was built up during the
pandemic that households have not burned
their way through yet so there is still
money to be had from consumer span
ending out there but if you look at some
specific areas such as hotels and
restaurants for example we'll uh output
their peaks in July of this year and it
really hasn't got back to that yet and
obviously the Christmas party season is
now upon us but we're hearing all sorts
of warnings from the hospitality sector
particularly about the impact of the
rail strikes they're not going to get us
a good Christmas season as they've been
hoping for last year of course was a
disaster because of the Omicron variant
that cropped up and this is the period
in which a lot of the hospitality sector
makes the majority of its money during
the course of the year so a good
Christmas party season is absolutely
vital and it doesn't look like they're
going to get that this year partly
because of the rail strikes and of
course now because uh parts of the
country are carpeted in snow as well